I'm in an airplane bathroom aboard a 777
somewhere over the mid-atlantic um it's
a long flight and this is a strange
place to film a video but it is the
perfect place to tell you about
relativity specifically that Einstein
was not the first person to have ideas
about relativity centuries earlier
Galileo came up with the concept of what
is now called Galilean relativity which
is the basic idea that's if you're in
well he would have been think about
something like here the whole of the
sailing ship but you're in an airplane
bathroom there is no physics experiment
you can do that will tell you how fast
you're going
you could be going 500 miles now has to
be hard you could be done in 9/10 it's
been appointed magically community burn
up to a cinder you could be stopped just
hovering dinner sometimes simulator and
this front is Union there is no way you
can tell because well you can't see what
you don't run to doing that idea that
there is no Triple H frame of references
and built upon by Einstein to realize
that if you are able to headway battery
dying at night ends the speed of light
and you turn the headlights of the plane
well the problems complain and see the
lines don't let the speed of light of an
observer would also see the speed of
mind that personal idea is where all of
relativity comes
the idea that there is no privilege is
very preference but that was Galileo's
idea centuries earlier and that is
something you might not have known
here's another thing if I was clever if
I was really clever and what I would do
is film it in a company and now my point
I would have the walls fall away
got about five hours left in his 40
you